[Müzik]
başarıyı Kim sevmez ki başarılı olmayı
takdir edilmeyi alkış almayı övgü almayı
Hatta imrenilmeyi ve kıskanılmayı başarı
insan için bir ihtiyaç hem de yemek
yemek su içmek uyku uyumak gibi önemli
bir ihtiyaç
Geçenlerde Ayıptır söylemesi evde dolma
yaptım
evdekiler çok beğendiler Ellerine sağlık
demekten bir hal oldular o an ben Oscar
ödül töreninde eline Oscar heykelciğini
almış bir aktörden daha az gururlu ve
Mutlu değildim
Evet böyle de Görece bir şeyi başarı
dediğimiz şey sizin için neyin değerli
olduğuna koşut olarak değişebiliyor
zamanın ruhuna ve zamana göre de
değişebiliyor misal Eskiden kalıcı ve
nitelikli başarı değerliydi insanlar
bunun peşinde koşarlardı şimdilerde
çabuk kazanılan ve nicelikli başarı
önemli nicelikli ne demek böyle bir
kelime yok tabii ki şu anda ben uydurdum
Yani şunu demek istiyorum başarı artık
sayısal değerleri endekslendi
tıklanmalara
like'lanmalara izlenmeleri endekslendi
ilk kitabın piyasaya çıktığı zaman
müthiş heyecan duymuştum
kitabın üstünde adımı ve kitabımı
raflarda görmek için kitapçı kitapçı
dolaştırdığımı hatırlıyorum o günlerde
şimdi düşündüğüm zaman bugün
Instagram'da bir paylaşımı bir postu
600-700.000
like alan birisi de benim o günlerde
hissettiğim kadar Mutlu ve gururlu
hissediyor olabilir dedim ya başarı
Görece bir şey Peki nasıl kazanılır
başarı başarılı olanlar nasıl oluyorlar
size bugün burada Bununla ilgili sihirli
ipuçları verecek değilim böyle ipuçları
varsa bile ben de bilmiyorum ama şunu
biliyorum uzun vadeli ve istikrar
gösteren bir emek ve çabanın insanı
Eninde sonunda hayallerine
kavuşturduğunu biliyorum çünkü bizzat
Yaşadım deneyimledim ve gördüm trajik ve
yazgıyı belirleyeceği anlara bireylerin
hayatlarında ve toplumların zamanın
tarihin akışı içerisinde çok Ender
rastlanır demiş İşte farz ürünü Almanya
yazar
ve bununla ilgili bir de kitap yazmış
insanlığın yıldızının parladığı anlar
adını taşıyan bu kitapta 1927 yılında
zweig'ın yazdığı Bu kitapta zweig
insanlığın tarihi içerisinde Bireylerin
ya da toplumların tarihini yazısını
değiştiren önemli 14 tane olayı
anlatıyor diyelim ki zwei bir o kadar
daha olay biliyordu ama kitabına koymadı
sadece 14 tanesini koydu hadi diyelim
bir o kadar da
yine de çok az değil mi
Oysa hepimiz
yıldızımızın parlayacağı o anı bekleriz
hayat boyunca
bende bekledim
ve elime geçen her fırsatta Tamam işte
yıldızımın parladığı an bu an dedim ama
sonra o anın o an olmadığını anladım
sonra bir daha sonra bir daha günün
birinde insanın yıldızının bir defada ve
bir daha hiç sönmemek üzere parladığı
bir an olmadığını anladım Bunu bana
kimse söylemedi ha söyleseydi de dinler
miydim onu da bilmiyorum Çünkü insan
genç yaşlarındayken çevresindekileri
asla dinlemiyor her zaman kendi iç
sesini dinlemeyi tercih ediyor
Kendimi Bildim Bileli müzikle ilgili bir
çocuktum müziği çok severdim şarkılar
dinlerdim sonra şarkılar söylemeye
başladım Sonra şarkılar yazmaya başladım
Sonra şarkılar üzerine yazılar yazmaya
başladım ilk müzik yazılarımı sarı saman
kağıtları kurşun kalemle yazardım ve ben
yazar ben okurdum benden başka kimse
okumazdı sonra Gülün birinde internette
bir yazım yayınlandı internetin daha
yeni yeni yaygınlaşmaya başladığı
zamanlarda ve ben internete konulan Bir
yazının internet sahibi olan herkes
tarafından okunacağına eminim
o kadar büyük bir heyecan duyuyordum ki
beni yazar olarak müzik yazar olarak
keşfedecekler ve bütün gazete ve
dergilerden bana köşe yazmam için
teklifler gelecek zannediyordum Yazım
yayınlandı ama hiçbir şey olmadı Neyse
ki ben yazmaktan vazgeçmedim yazmaya
devam ettim yazdıkça yazdım yazdıkça
yazdım yazdıkça üstüne yenilerini
koydukça o ilk yazdıklarımın aslında o
kadar da iyi olmadığını aslında o kadar
da Yetkin olmadığımı farkına vardım
müzik tarihi üzerine kitaplar okudum
Araştırmalar yaptım müzik üzerine
kitaplar okudum eleştiri kuramı üzerine
kitaplar okudum ve hem o ilk başladığım
sitede hem başka sitelerde Hem de kendi
açtığım blokta 9 sene boyunca yazılar
yazmaya devam ettim artık müzik
sektöründe tanınmaya başlayan ve
yazdıkları dikkate alınan bir müzik
eleştirmeliydi 9 yılın sonunda bir gün
Milliyet sanat dergisinden bana yazmam
için teklif geldi ve ben lise yıllarında
düzenli olarak alıp okuduğum o dergide
Milliyet sanat dergisinde artık düzenli
olarak yazı yazıyordu dedim yani müzikle
çok ilgiliydim diye aldığım her şeyi de
müzik dergileri diller kasetler plaklar
hepsini de saklardım içki güzel bir
biriktirme duygusuydu bu arşivcilik
yapmak maksadıyla değil de Çünkü
arşivciliğin nedir ne değildir o konuda
da çok fazla fikrim yoktu açıkçası
Fakat o biriktirdiklerim o arşiv bana
yazılarımda faydalı olmaya başladı
onlardan istifade etmeye başladım bir
süre sonra radyo programı yapmaya
başladım ve o zaman o arşiv
imi kullan mecra çıktı karşıma ilk Radyo
programını yapacağım zaman çok
Acemi bir afiş hazırladım paint'te Ya bu
saatten tok'un radyo programı başlıyor
diye bir afiş hazırladım o zamanlar
gazetelerde köşe yazarlarının mail
adresleri de yayınlanırdı Çünkü
internetin yeni yeni yaygınlaşmaya
başladığı dönemde dedim ya mail adresi
sahibi olmak çok havalı bir şeydi Ben
bütün gazete ve dergilerden o yazarların
mail adreslerini topladım ve o
hazırladığım Acemi afişi herkese
gönderdi zannediyorum ki programın
yayınlandığı gün ve saatte herkes
radyonun ya da internetin başına geçecek
ve benim programımı dinleyecek o kadar
özgün bir program yapıyorum ki o kadar
iyi bir program yaptığımı düşünüyorum ki
ama yine hiç öyle bir şey olmadı Ben 3
yıl boyunca programı yapmaya devam ettim
ve 3 yılın sonunda program Ankara'da
yavaş yavaş duyulup tanınmaya
başlamışken TRT Ankara televizyondan
Bana bir teklif geldi Radyo Programıma
benzer bir televizyon programı yapmam
için bir teklif geldi yaptım dönüttekim
200-300 bölüm kadar
yarı belgesel nitelikli bir programın
metinlerine imza attım bu deneyim bana
yıllar sonra yapacağım onlarca
televizyon programı ve belgesel için ilk
gücü cesareti kazandırdı Böylece
1999 yılında Nükhet Duru'nun başrolünü
oynadığı Yedi Kocalı Hürmüz müzikali
sahnelenecekti ben o müzikalde bazı
şarkı sözlerini yazdım o kadar
heyecanlıyım ki işte dedim yıldızımın
parladığı bu anı artık beni
keşfedecekler Çünkü Nükhet Duru bizim
Çocukluğumuzun O dönemin en büyük
starlarından biri ve benim yazdığım
şarkı sözlerini söyleyecek sahnede
bundan daha ötesi yok benim için
insanlar beni şarkı sözü yazarı olarak
keşfedecekler artık buna inanıyorum
gazeteler ve dergiler benim peşimde
koşacaklar röportaj yapmak için de hatta
sokakta beni gösterecekler bakın İşte o
yetenekli söz yazarı diyecekler
Ama tahmin ettiğiniz gibi yine hiç öyle
bir şey olmadı
buradan Ankara'dan İstanbul'a geliyorduk
her hafta sonu müzikali izlemek için
bilirsiniz tiyatroların fuayelerinde
oyuna emeği geçenlerin fotoğraflarını
yer aldığı panolar asılır ben kendi
fotoğrafımın olduğu panonun yanında
şöyle duruyordum belki beni Bir tanıyan
Bir gören olur Benim de iki satır bir
şey Konuşurlar şarkı sözü ne kadar güzel
derler diye ama bir Allah'ın kulu gelip
bir şey sormadık konuşmadı benimle
fotoğrafın bana baktı Ben fotoğrafıma
baktım aradan 19 yıl geçti 2018 yılının
yaz aylarında Gazete ve dergilerde ve
televizyonların bütün Kültür Sanat
programlarında yeni sahnelenecek bir
müzikalden bahsediliyordu ve o müzikalin
haberlerinde Benim de adım geçiyordu
Üstelik bu sefer
gazete ve dergiler benimle röportaj
yapıyordu Çünkü o müzikalin yazarı
bendim
şayet 1999 yılında 7 Kocalı Hürmüz
müzikalinin kulesine girmemiş olsaydım
provalarını izlememiş olsaydım o havayı
teneffüs etmemiş olsaydım 2018 yılında
bana Seninle Başım Dertte müzikali için
teklif geldiği zaman Belki de buna evet
deme cesaretini gösteremeyecektim 1999
yılında yaşadığım O büyük hayal
kırıklığı beni farkında olmadan 2018
yılına hazırlamıştı
şimdi bunları böyle anlatıyorum
anlatmasına ama bunları yaşarken şu anda
anlattığım kadar rahat değildim mümkün
değil zaten böyle bir şey çok üzüldüm
Çok kahroldum vazgeçme noktasına geldim
Çünkü Acelem vardı çünkü çok gençtim de
birileri benim hayal ettiğim şeyleri
yapıyordu Ben onları seyretmek zorunda
kalıyordum ama ben bir adım ileri
gidiyorsam iki adım geri gidiyordu
Nerede hata yaptığımı da bilmiyordum ama
Bugün baktığım zaman nerede doğru
yaptığımı biliyorum
vazgeçme noktasına geldiğim çok hayal
kırıklıkları yaşadığım anlarda ya da
kendimi çok Yetkin çok olmuş Her şeyi
biliyor zannettiğim zamanlarda bile asla
yaptıklarımın üstüne daha fazlasını
koymak için koymaktan vazgeçmedim hep
koymak için çabaladım
ve ismimin yazdığı kitaplar gördüm
raflarda
içinde söz yazarı ve besteci olarak
adımın geçtiği albümler gördüm CD'ler
kasetler gördüm oyunlar yazdım
sayısız televizyon programı ve
belgeselde Metin yazarı ve Danışman
olarak jenerikte adımın geçtiğini gördüm
Bütün bunlar benim hayal
ettiği zaman parladığı an bu an dediğim
anlarda olmadı ama bir şekilde Zamanı
gelince oldu
bahsetmiştim konuşmamın başında Ondan
bir örnek vereceğim şimdi zweig 26
yaşındayken artık çok tanınan iyi kötü
tanınan bir yazardır fakat kendini
yeterince olgun bir eser veremediğini
düşünmektedir Bu maksatla da bir tiyatro
oyunu yazar çok ağır bir dram yazar hiç
ticari bir oyun değildir Bu O yüzden de
zweig'ın bir beklentisi yoktur Sadece
kendini tatmin etmek için hazırlamıştır
yazmıştır Bu oyunu ama enteresan bir şey
olur ve Rusya Devleti tiyatrosundan zıva
bu oyunu sahnelemek için teklif gelir
üstelikte oyunun başrolünde O dönemin en
ünlü tiyatro oyuncusu adelvet matkowski
oynayacaktır bu zıvık için bir zirvedir
yıldızının parladığı an belki de o andır
genç bir tiyatro oyun yazarı ve Rusya
Devlet Tiyatrosu matkinin başrolü
oynadığı bir oyun
büyük bir heyecanla oyunun sahneleneceği
günü beklemeye başlar provalar yapılır
fakat sonra premier'in ertelendiği
haberi duyulur Birkaç zaman sonra da
oyunun başrol oyuncusu matkovski'nin
öldüğü haberi gelir
zweight çok üzülür büyük bir hayal
kırıklığı Yaşar Çünkü oyun iptal olur
aradan bir süre zaman geçtikten sonra
aynı oyun için başka bir oyuncu Talip
olur çok önemli bir başka oyuncu
josephends Talip olur ancak josephes'ın
direktörü bu oyunun sahnelenmesine çok
yanaşması dediğin gibi ticari bir oyun
değildir Çünkü kanser bunun üzerine işte
fansızlıktan onun için özel yeni bir
oyun tek kişilik bir oyun yazmasını
ister zweig yine Müthiş bir heyecan
Duyar ve kaleme sarılır Gerçekten de çok
güzel bir oyun yazar ve hem Joseph
Khan'ın hem de direkt türü bu oyunu çok
beğenirler
josephense o günlerde bir turneye
çıkacak ve turne dönüşünde de bu yeni
oyunun provalarına başlayacaktır
çıkar turne dönüşü hastaneye kaldırılır
ve kanser teşhisi konulur birkaç hafta
sonra da Josef kines ölür
çok acayip değil mi Ama hikaye Burada da
bitmiyor
aradan on yıl geçer ve
zwei ka çok yakın arkadaşı olan ve yine
çok önemli bir tiyatro oyuncusu olan
Alexander muasi bir teklif getirir bir
oyununu sahnelemek ve başrolde oynamak
istemektedir zweig bu teklifi kabul
etmez ve izin vermez bu Asiye bunun
üzerine muasi ona başka bir teklif
getirir önemli bir İtalyan yazarın
İtalyanca bir oyununu Almancaya
çevirmesini ister oyun Viyana'da
sahnelenecektir ve çok görkemli bir Gala
ile izleyici karşılığına çıkacaktır
bunu kabul eder Nasıl olsa oyunu Ben
yazdım şu an diye düşünür ve çeviriyi
yapar oyunun provaları başlar zıvak da o
günlerde viyana'dadır
ve bir gün gazeteyi Açtığı Zaman
Alexander muasinin hastalandığı haberini
görür
birkaç haftaya kalmadan muhasebe
her sonra zweig bütün bu yaşadıklarını
şöyle değerlendiriyor
gayet o oyunlar
o günlerde sahnelenseydi
en başarısız işi bile başarırlığı
gösterebilecek o oyuncular ve
yönetmenler sayesinde ben
Belki de Haketmediğim çok erken gelen
bir başarının sahibi olacak geniş
kitlelerle tanışacaktım ama sindire
sindire öğrenmekten ve dünyayı tanıyıp
görmekten mahrum kalacaktım insanlar
genç yaşlarındayken üst üste gelen
rastlantısal olayları Yazgı zannederler
Kader zannederler Oysa hayatın gerçek
yolunun kendi iç Dünyamız tarafından
belirlendiği ancak çok uzun yıllar sonra
anlaşılır
kişisel gelişim öğretilerinin ısrarla
yinelediği bir şey var isteğin olur
isterseniz olur evrene gönderin ve
bekleyin bana sorsalar
Onu şöyle değiştirmek isterdim
isteyince olmaz
istediğiniz için çaba gösterince emek
harcayınca ve karşılaştığınız engellere
rağmen vazgeçmeyince olur
vazgeçersiniz zaten olmaz
vazgeçmeyince olur Teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]